انطلقت فاعاليات الدوله الرابعه عشر لمعرض
الصين الدولي للطيران في مدينه جوخ هاي
جنوبيه البلاد وذلك بمشاركه اكثر من 740
شركه 43 دوله ويعد الموارد الذي يستمر سته
ايام منصه للصين والدول المشاركه لعرض
احدث التقنيات في تكنولوجيا الطيران
المدني والعسكري وكشفت بجين هذا العام عن
احدث اصداراتها من الطائرات المقاتله
والمسيره العابره للقارات
جديده من قوه الردع هو شعار بيتين في
الدوره الرابعه عشر من معرض الصين الدولي
للطيران ومع ان المعرض الذي يقام كل سنتين
يشمل صناعه الطيران المدني والعسكري فان
الصناعات العسكريه اصبحت تحتل الجزء
الاكبر منه
السلاح لتجربه اخر الاصدارات والافتخار
بما حققه جيشنا في تطويرها
ازي حضرتك لاول مره عن المقاتلات الشبح
جاي 20 التي تلقب بالتنين العظيم وتملك
الصين نحو 200 طائره منها وبها غاده الصين
ثانيه دوله في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحده التي تمتلك مقاتلات من الجيل
الخامس
كما عرض الطائرات وين لون المسيره من
الجيل الثالث العابره للقارات والقادره
على حملي 16 صاروخا وقنبله اصدارات
مستقطبت صفقات اسلحه جديده للشركات
الصينيه
السابقه حيث بلغت صفقات الشراء نحو سبعه
مليارات دولار امريكي ويعتبر هذا تايدا
لمنتجاتنا تصدر الصين المنتجات العسكريه
لاكثر من 50 دوله منها دول في افريقيا
والشرق الاوسط متفوقه بذلك على روسيا
لتصبح ثانيه اكبر منتجا للاسلحه في العالم
تحتل الصناعات العسكريه تحيز مهما في معرض
الصين الدولي للطيران وهو ما يعاكس توجهها
بيجين نحو تطوير منظومتها الدفاعيه في
الوقت الذي تتصاعد فيه التوترات في مضيق
تايوان حريق جنوب الصين
توترات دفعت بيجين الى نشر اكثر من 100
طائره مقاتله من طراز جاي 20 على طول
الشريط الساحلي الجنوبي لها مع تكثيف
الدوريات والتدريبات في منطقه بحر جنوب
الصين الهدف منها ان يكون الجيش في كامل
جاهزيته القتاليه امر ترى فيه واشنطن
تهديدا يستدعي تمديد حاله الطوارئ
المتعلقه بالصين
زمام مبادره لمهاجمه الولايات المتحده او
اي دوله كل استعدادات القتاليه للصين هي
استعدادات لصد غاره وحجمه خارجيه
من استعاده تايوان بالقوه العسكريه تتزايد
خصوصا بعد تاكيد الرئيس الصيني عدم
استبعاده استخدام القوه لاسترداد ما تراه
الص جزءا لا يتجزا من اراضيها شيماء
الجزيره
جنوبيه الصين